[Applause]
yes so once upon a time a long very long
time ago there was a people known as the
Romans and of course you all know a lot
about the Romans they are famous for
being very good engineers they created
paved roads aqueducts great great
buildings are still standing today a
little bit less well-known is that they
also invented the modern sleek tablet
computer so this is actually it's a
pocket-sized bronze abacus that from
ancient Rome that Roman engineers could
use to do a lot of advanced calculations
and they had to use a computer because
the number system they had the Roman
numerals are not very good for doing
arithmetic of course yeah they're pretty
much good for one thing and there is
writing down a number it's easy to see
that this is a 23rd see plot Sweden C++
meetup or stockings it was just made up
but have you tried doing arithmetic
where Roman numerals it's addition
subtraction is relatively easy but
multiplication it's quite a lot more
complicated and yeah also engineers need
more numbers than the natural numbers
but let's go back even further in time
so where do the natural numbers come
from that's basically how math started
and this is a picture of the Shango bone
this is very early archeological finding
from a mathematical nature it's it was
from the Shango region which is
modern-day Democratic Republic of Congo
it's over 20,000 years old and it's not
very clear here perhaps but there it's
full of this little scratches they're
made by some human hand and they are not
just random scratches actually if you
look at them a little bit closer there
are kind of three rows
on the first row there is kind of series
of doubling so you have three six four
eight there is a ten followed by two
groups of five and the second two rows
are all odd numbers in fact of the
second middle row there is all prime
numbers and they both add up to 60 so
there's seems to be some mathematical
thinking going here and yeah this is how
we believe that natural numbers started
like you just count things and make some
kind of marks so like a prehistoric
definition this is a unary system you
make a doctor line or something to count
things and we could implement such a
number type and C++ if we wanted to so
this is a stone-age natural number type
it's just a standard string of dots so
we start with 1 and if a stone-age
person comes with a string of different
characters different things they want to
count we just create the string of dots
not longer we can do Mareth Matic with
this but of course it's not very
practical the strings grow quite long if
the number grows large it becomes
difficult to see like how many how big
is this number it's a lot of work to do
the calculations so the next natural
step is to group the numbers into equal
sized groups somehow and invent new
symbols which many ancient civilizations
came up with independently of each other
so that's an example from Babylonians
used a base 60 system we pressed reads
into clay tablets and they used a
different way they did it in a different
way for the temps to keep the digits
manageable like on a different continent
the Mayans they had a base 20 system
where they had like horizontal lines for
the fives and so on and of course this
is how Roman numerals work as well is
the same basic idea makes it possible to
write much larger numbers
and the next step of course by the time
the Roman Empire started to disintegrate
the Indians of course invented the
modern number system that went through
the Far East and the Arab world and it
took a very long time until the
beginning of 13th century when Fibonacci
brought these numbers to Western Europe
yes this is a Mayan numbers this is a
bubble ona's yeah and I don't know
exactly if they thought of it as a
normal number or like a special kind of
way of writing zero but many ancient
civilization had some kind of zero but
yeah it was some kind of weird thing and
it was with the Indians that it sort of
became a real thing but yeah so it took
a long time to go into Europe and even
when it came to Europe it took a very
long time before it was adopted by
anyone acceptable like were very
well-educated people here's a proof of
this this is a woodcut a picture of an
astronomical clock that was in the
cathedral Uppsala sadly it got destroyed
in the city fire in 1702 but this is
this was my 300 years after the
hindu-arabic numbers came to Europe and
still apparently there was a written
need to have two clock faces - so that
you can see what the time was
and also clocks are interesting they
have kind of relics from ancient
civilization like the 24 hours in a day
that comes from the Egyptian timekeeping
system and the six days in in minutes
and hours comes from Babylonian base 60
system and this 24 and 60 are very
practical numbers because they are
highly composite there are so many ways
you could divide them into
equal for integer fractions which is
very practical for timekeeping very
practical for trade and so on so of
course ancient civilizations knew a lot
about fractions our or as you call them
today rational numbers so here's like a
modern definition of rational numbers as
you remember from school it's an ordered
pair PQ of integers where Q is not
allowed to be zero and we write them as
P over Q where that like horizontal -
it's related to division but it's not
division the number is this pair of two
integers mathematicians say that
rational numbers form what's called a
field which is a mathematical type with
addition subtraction multiplication and
division in the normal sense so we're
going to go into that a bit more later
so let's try to implement rational
numbers in C++ and see what we can learn
from that because C++ it it doesn't have
a rational number type for runtime use
so that's it implement our own so we can
start simple with two int to approximate
integers and it makes sense to
initialize it to zero right it's useful
to be able to convert from in to
irrational so we can carry the
constructor from that and of course you
want to be able to construct the
rational from two ends and then they're
there there's a precondition of course
x1 is not allowed to be 0 that's not a
badly rational number so you can check
that in various ways but what I did here
was I use this new new C++ 20 contracts
syntax Bjorn Fowler's talked about this
before and meetup group great talk but I
don't have contracts enabled compiler
yet so I just put it behind comments
it's just uh just for the future but
even as documentation I think this is
quite clear yes ok so now we can go on
to the fun stuff implement some
operators
and starting with the relational
operators first of all the quality as
you remember from school two rational
numbers are equal if you can do this
when you this crosswise multiplication
of the integers from these two integer
products are equal then the rational
numbers are equal which also means there
can be many equal implement definitions
of the same rational number one half and
two fourth three six four eight it's
exactly the same number just a different
representation why is it quality
important well of course it enables
equation or reasoning we're gonna have
put two rational numbers and equations
and there's the equal sign in the middle
of every equation so there's that the
laws of arithmetic for rational numbers
are defined in terms of equalities so we
need this they're a more like C++
programmers view of this is that
equality enables linear search if you
have an array of rational numbers I can
put some number in a random position you
can find it again we still find
comparing for equality okay
so let's implement the quality operator
and already there's a problem right what
happens if P and Q are large integers we
could overflow and that's undefined
behavior so it can break equality so you
have some design decision to do here
right so you can make up cost it the
bigger type you could try to store it in
reduced form factoring out all the
common factors to keep the numbers low
or you could use some unlimited
precision in to your type from some
library maybe but I I don't want to
worry about that for now so let's just
assume we have small integers of course
when you have an equality operator you
always need to implement in equality
operator as well and there's a post
condition on the inner code right it's
the compliment of equality when one
returns through the other one
turns fourths and the other way around
you can produce a there's a post
condition and equality as well but the
standard ways to just implement equality
and your implant inequality by calling
equality and negating the result because
like these two belong together any
sensible programmer will expect that
they can use if they can use one of them
like each other what's the name of that
operator by the way well I think the C++
down there calls it not equals could be
wrong
I found this Dykstra the famous Dutch
computer scientist he was very
particular about word naming things
correctly it was very important in
programming this opinion so he called
this operator this is from a letter like
beginning of 80s I think where he
discusses what is going to name
mathematical symbols in his future texts
and he calls it differs from just to
emphasize that just one may be
implemented in terms of the other but to
the user they are symmetric so you
shouldn't think of inequality as being
something kind of less importance or
less fundamental thing I thought that
was kind of interesting some properties
of equality that always need to hold if
you implement equality operator and
object all is equal to itself right and
if you can compare to obvious or equal
you should be able to compare them in
the other order and if you have three
objects were the first is equal to the
second second sequence of the third you
never should need to check if the first
is equal to the third so if you have
those properties you have with much
mathematicians called
equivalence relation and there can be
many interesting equivalence relations
on some type for example here in a
stupid function that takes two objects
and always returns true always that will
be an equivalence relation but perhaps
not that interesting but yeah if you
want to write immune
tests or something for a quality
operator these are things you should
check rational numbers are also ordered
there's total ordering it's the same
formula but with a left sign instead of
equality which is also important for
numbers it enables fundamental
algorithms within math like taking the
absolute value of a number like is it
bigger or smaller than zero you need an
ordering it also enables sorting so if
you have if you implement relational
operators you can store your objects
instead set or as keys instead map so it
becomes much more powerful type and of
course if you can sort you can do a
binary search in in an ordered set in an
ordered sequence instead of linear
search and find something much quicker
yes yeah I don't assume it yet perhaps
and you say I need more than just
ordering that's true I yeah I will come
back to that but it's one of the things
you need is ordering ok implementation
pretty straightforward but since there
it's not symmetric like it's not an
equivalence relation so you have the
four operators instead of just to the
complement greater than equal the
converse if you flip them you get
greater than and the complement of
converse if you flip and the gate you
get less than or equal so you only need
to implement one and the other three you
just call that one it doesn't matter
which one you implement but the
convention is to use less in C++ okay so
what what is this total ordering it's
there are many kinds of orderings and
maybe not all of them are important to
know I think it's for programming there
are two that are really the most
important it's weak ordering first
well which is a it's transitive just
like an equivalence relation so if X
comes before Y and Y it comes to prefer
said then you don't need to check if it
hey X should always come before said if
you couldn't know that then sorting
would not be possible to implement in an
efficient way for example and the other
thing is the weak trichotomy law that
says that you can compare any two
objects like any two rational numbers
you can compare and it's one of three
cases either one the first is lesson the
second or a second lesson the first or
if none it comes before the other then
they are equivalent in so there's some
equivalence relation there and then and
the other the thing you need to do to
make the total ordering is simply to use
equality as that equivalence relation so
this is like how all the these
relational operators tie together so in
c++ xx we will get this new spaceship
operator and think before you start
playing too much with that it's you
should know what a total ordering is and
think about using it correctly okay so
now we have like what basics what we
need to implement addition
multiplication subtraction and division
ok so let's do a little detour here so
this is a piece of pseudocode
it's obviously not C++ might look like
some language you know but it's not it's
I just made this up so what do you think
this would print threes and cpp you're
right it's make sense what about this
one good what about this one
doesn't make sense thank yes it's
regular I think it makes sense I think
it should print Sweden's TPP but that's
wait a minute here
so which one of these are correct we
have two operators they do the same
thing that doesn't make sense this is
badly designed language so which one
should we pick yes yeah the could be a
possibility yes yeah so yeah think about
for a second which one you would pick
and let's see if we don't right so I
think standard string got it wrong
but we're in good bad company here
because the same thing in Java Python
will just list the popular languages all
use plus for string concatenation so how
can it be wrong that's a good thing
right
we have some tradition here all these
programming languages are consistent so
if you move to a new language that
you're not familiar with you will
recognize what that plus means right but
sometimes traditions can be problematic
they could clash with other traditions
and there's a tradition in mathematics
here that says that whenever they use
Plus whenever mathematicians use plus
it's usually used to denote a
commutative operation so if you swap the
terms you get the equal results it holds
for all the standard number types
polynomials you can add them together
it's commutative vectors matrices like
give me any mathematical type that has
plus if it's not commutative a
mathematician will have to explain that
and say oh no it's non commutative plus
so what about strings string
concatenation commutative with this to
print the same string
I'm gonna get to that so what about
multiplication right it's also
commutative right well usually yes for
all common number types that we learn in
school for polynomials you can multiply
it by themselves or by a scalar it's
commutative either way vectors can be
multiplied by scalars or the commutative
but matrices remember matrix
multiplication like you have to do every
value and there is resulting matrix is
and in their product you take a row and
a column and you multiply each the
elements and then you add them together
because of that in order to even
variable swap matrices they have to be
square matrices and when you swap your
the rows and columns which rolls so
usually you don't get the same result
right same think returned Ian's reusing
computer graphics as also like in
general if you don't know the type of x
and y there you cannot be sure that it's
a commutative operation so from that
perspective maybe multiplication is okay
to use for Strings for concatenation you
could then you could use the same symbol
to x number or another string or and
also there's another tradition in
mathematics that you usually don't print
the multiplication sign right you say 3x
not 3 times X and that you can do in C++
with string literals right you put a
space between and they are concatenated
a compile-time
so if you ever implement the string type
so think about which tradition you
follow right yeah so that that
multiplication follows from a series of
additions that holds four natural
numbers and not for all mathematical
types though it could be a completely
different thing so yeah something to
think about
so let's say you want to implement
either multiplication or addition so
there's a much more you
important law that then commutativity
it's the associative law like the second
thing we second lower arithmetic that we
learned in school so if you have a
serious sequence of three or more and
you want to add them all and multiply
them together you can put parentheses
and do them in different order as long
as you don't move them around this is
hugely useful for programming right you
should always look for societal
operations in your code and why is that
well let's look at a simple example so
here we have a sequence of strings
separate words and I want to reduce them
all into a single sentence single string
string concatenation is associative
right this very simple to see that which
means that yeah we could do this we
could turn this into one string
sequentially below just appending a word
at the time but since it's associative
we can actually put parentheses and we
can do this two sub strings in two or
sub sequences of strings in two separate
threads or two separate processes or
computers in a network like whatever
resources we have we could paralyze this
right and it's kind of trivial to
paralyze there's no shared state here
there's no need for locks or mutexes any
kind of synchronization there are two
separate parts and when they're done we
just concatenate them together and we
get the correct result the cost of a
subjectivity and it doesn't depend on
being strings or string concatenation
this could work for any type that has an
associative operator so mathematicians
have a name for this ver use the thing
they call the semi group so how many
know what the semi group is hello how
many of them yeah a few right so it's if
you're unfamiliar it's a very basic idea
so you can think of it as some data type
T right together with a binary operation
represented by that
Circle so this could be plus could be
multiplication could be any named
function that takes two T's and returns
a T combining them in some way if that
operation is associative then that whole
thing is called a semi-group now T it
doesn't have to be a complete data type
even like mathematician think of it as a
set so it could be the subset of values
within a type on some subset on which
the operator is defined so C++ is full
of semi groups they appear everywhere
like int with plus or multiplication
name function like stood min min is
clearly associative as well all the
boolean binary operators stood string
with concatenation like in all these
cases you could do this parallelization
trick right but not every type for
example floating-point numbers are
problematic there are many problems with
floating-point numbers it could be a
whole talk like the I Triple E floating
point standards are kind of designed by
commit to things where they forgot about
basic mathematics more or less so which
is a big problem like my makes it hard
to parallel Allies code with floating
point numbers and get consistent results
yeah so many semi groups also have an
extra bonus feature and yes sir
yeah I mean it has to do with overflow
and underflow and so on there is
research in that there is I looked into
it a little bit it's a difficult thing
to change because it's implemented in
hardware floating-point numbers but yeah
there is a guy called John gust
Gustafson it's not he's not Swedish even
if his name sounds like that and yes
there's a type younam's a type that is
kind of yeah there are it's quite new
things so they all right yeah
theoretically possible of to fix this
but it will take a long time to do it in
practice but yeah yes so many semi
groups have this extra feature that
there is a special value in the set
special value for a type that when you
combine that value with any value it
doesn't change anything if you have that
kind of value you have what's called a
monoid and that's called an identity
element or e so actually all the
examples of semi groups that I had are
also mono it's because there's an
identity on for int and plus it's zero
right to add zero nothing changes from
multiplication it's one multiplied by
one nothing changes for mean it's the
biggest int like the mean of any int and
the biggest ents the other one for
Strings empty string right concatenate
them to string nothing changes so
Mahanoy two are very common very useful
as well one thing they do is they allow
you to deal with empty ranges so think
about like what's the sum of no integers
what's the string you getting for
concatenate no strings
what should you return empty string Oh
thank you
yeah so it's good to look for an
identity element as well and third law
of arithmetic that we learn in school
Howard multiplication and addition
connected with distributive law to do
multiplication first you it distributes
over addition
and of course mathematicians have a
clever name for this well called the
semi ring which is simply a type with
two operators right it's one we call
addition with zero being the identity
one we call multiplication with one
being the identity so they are both
monoids the plus is commutative the
identity elements are distinct from each
other and the distributive law also if
you have that whole thing together it's
a the type is a semi ring so again like
classical into normal addition
multiplication bool where you use or as
addition and and this multiplication
like am distributes over or that's a
boolean semi ring another famous one is
so tropical semi ring where you use min
as your plus and there's plus as your
multiplication so like plus distributes
over me and this good luck exercise to
convince yourself that works these are
yeah so it doesn't have to be literally
plus your multiplication but here yep
sorry
yes definitely
this is this tropical algebra you can
use it for path finding algorithms for
example it's yeah it's worth looking
into it's quite cool okay so this is
like old theory for now or abstract
algebra so now let's look like how do
you add two rational numbers we'll learn
how to do it it's cool you have the
common denominator so you multiply them
and then you have to multiply on top to
compensate so it's kind of a
expensive operation right you have three
multiplications and one addition just
multiply the right rational numbers and
it also make them quite a bit this
enters a bit large so but this is both
commutative and associative and there's
an identity element the rational number
zero so here's like and proof of that
you can easily see it's just on either
side you just be get the other one
so we implement addition exactly as math
textbooks multiplication is easier
cheaper to do on an addition you just
multiply the PS and QS and you get the
product also associative and commutative
and identity element one there's the
proof of that
so we have multiplication so we have
addition multiplication so now we have a
new semi-ring of this rational number
type but we also want to be able to
subtract it's the same formulas addition
but with - on top so we could implement
it like that but there's more general
way to do it also so that you need to go
one level up from monoids into a group
and the group is just a monoid with
another extra feature that you have for
every element you can find an inverse
element and when you combine them they
cancel each other so their salt is the
identity element so the only one here
that is qualifies as a group kind of is
int with plus because yeah you're
positive int find the negative int and
then you combine them and they become
zero there's a slight problem there so
like do you see it how are it's
implemented usually
exactly it's a two's complement there's
one extra negative into the smallest one
that has no inverse okay so we have to
sort of okay yeah we really don't care
about that one we yeah but like overflow
is also a problem and that's yeah but it
doesn't mean that addition is broken or
anything like that we are worrying about
overflow and this kind of bad things
happening at the limits we're used to
dealing with that so so but what's the
point of group well imagine you have a
group your operation is plus what is the
name of the function that gets you the
inverse element in C++ your honor - yes
so an additive group is just a group
with plus and 0 where the additive
inverse is a unary minor so this
function added to be inverses is the
bogus function call you have what you
have to do there is whatever you have to
do for the type to find the inverse
element it's built in of course for him
ok but if you have that you know - you
can implement a proper subtraction just
by taking the first time element plus
the negation of the other one ok so we
could do this rational numbers it works
so we have to how do you negate a
natural rational number values negate
the numerator okay and it turns out it's
a exactly the same thing - to add the
negative rational number rational number
so let's implement it like that so we
have the unary operator - just negate
the numerator and we implement my binary
- with plus and the unit - it already
did so that function is different from
the previous ones it it doesn't use a
piece and QS directly so and this should
work for any group and edit your group I
should say not just rational number so
we could consider making this a template
right so G is some additive group type
we could implement - for
any such tea but I don't really like the
tightening keyword it doesn't say
anything about the type and of course
this is something but this is what
concepts come in it's this new C++
feature where you can design a concept
that says it describes that the type has
to have a plus and a minus for example
but if you if you don't have concepts
yet if you're not familiar with them
that's ok we can sort of sheet so I'm
going to make a macro and say that again
yeah so tie additive group is just a
different name for type name so then we
can put say additive group there it's
just documentation but it's it's good it
actually is better than the type name
and then later when you have concepts
maybe you can implement the concept and
check that and get better error messages
ok so I'm gonna do this in the rest of
the talk like if you see something out
the other than tightening your threes is
tightening okay so now we have the minus
and that means our rational type forms a
ring so the semi the missing part was
that the addition was just an additive
monoid not agree so they were not
inverses but we have inverses with no
group and then its color ring so the
rational numbers form a ring and the
traditional or they like the canonical
example of a ring is the integers inch
you can add subtract multiply and you
get done in it but integers have more
properties than just this so they form
what's called integral domain something
integer like so an integral domain is a
ring where multiplication is commutative
and there's another thing another
property that I think it can be
expressed in different ways but one way
is to say there are no serial divisors
so if you multiply to int and the result
is 0 you know that one of them or both
are 0 or conversely if you multiply in
the result it's not 0 none none of them
could have been 0 and that leads to
division so that's rational number
division yeah it's just multiplication
over the integers but to do it this
crosswise way and of course it's
undefined if the numerator becomes zero
so P one cannot be zero because it's an
integral domain if piece q0 can also not
be zero but then you didn't have a
rational number to begin with there in
the top but you could have division by
zero is p1 with 0 and that's undefined
so division has a precondition again
like it's yeah you're not allowed to
divide by 0 and that's now all we have
that leads to a field so the rational
numbers the field it has all these four
operators in this particular way so
field is just an integral domain with a
inverses for multiplication as well
except for 0 and you could if you want
to implement division sort of like you
did subtraction but using multiplication
instead of plus okay so that's a lot of
words a lot of rules to remember and it
kind of it's hard to keep track of so
but I think it helps to like draw them
in a diagram like to see how they are
connected to each other and how they are
related to the operators for the like
this and this I call the algebraic
concepts so like this new feature
concepts what does it come from it
suggests something in the standards
committee wants to have to improve
compile times to get better their error
messages with templates no literally the
idea of concept comes from abstract
algebra so it's it's modeled after this
very kind useful idea from mathematics
mathematicians don't call them concepts
they call them algebraic structures but
it's the same thing almost concepts also
say something about computational
complexity so we want this to be fast as
well which many mathematicians don't
care about but they should probably
but yeah so so this is a like a good way
how to think about concepts they come
from mathematics okay so so we aren't
with this all this theory we could look
at this rational number type and think
about generalizing it right so we put an
int but we didn't know the operators
used in directly they just used equality
less than addition negation and
multiplication and they assumed those
properties right so we could make this
whole rational number into type into a
template as well where you should work
on any integral domain I so it could be
like a library integer type for example
something you make up yourself and
there's no change you would have to
templatized the operators as well but
this is varying great but there's one
extra thing here that I don't really
like okay so it's this there's an extra
property we sort of require the type I
to have a constructor that takes in
working convert to int and where the
interior literals 0 and 1 mean the
additive and multiplicative identity
elements like a serum one is for
whatever that integral domain type is so
maybe we don't have that so what can we
do to fix that well we could replace 0
and 1 by 0 and 1 britainís text instead
ok so what are the zero on one here
clearly they are some kind of templates
because you have low angle brackets
clearly they are still values because
you need values here not types or
anything else but what you really should
do is like take off your C++ classes
take on your math classes and look at
that as a function call right so serum 1
or some kind of mathematical function
where you pass in the type I and it
returns at compile time
the
what's Iran one represents for that type
so this is a type function and you
cannot implement that with a normal C++
function they only take values no types
but you can implement them using crates
classes this was standard library that's
a lot so the function is actually a
struct called 0 TF 4 type function it's
a template destruct which contains only
a static constant called value which I
default initialize to calling the
constructor with 0 so if s is an int
values is the number 0 but the beauty of
this is of course if you have some other
type where 0 is not implemented like
that you could specialize that striked
and provide your own value and to access
that you would have to say c OT f of s
comma colon value that's a little bit
much type so i think it's nice to use
variable templates that came in c++ 14
there so that's that's just 0 is just a
different name for that so that's that's
what 0 was in there up there it's just a
static constant and 1 is the same thing
default initial is 2 1 but of course
rational numbers now so now this works
for int for example but rational numbers
also have this 0 and 1 so we could
specialize we should provide this for
rational numbers as well so it's a bit
of a wall or code here but first you
have the specialization for 0 and here I
put the definition outside so this value
is what rational default constructor
returns so it's 0 / 1 + 1 is 1 / 1 for
that into your type okay so now let's
sort of we create the rational numbers
and they are completely abstracted away
but the interior type is okay so we
could
use use this to implement a lot of other
types without even knowing what specific
int type use so what I did I implemented
this little C++ program you can download
it later if you're interested it's it's
not a library or anything it's just a
single CPP file no dependencies on
anything but the standard library should
work in all three major compilers and it
just has some unit tests and a bunch of
mathematical types so I built this
rational number type and on top of that
for example if you simple geometry to
the Yama tree you can construct 2d
vector just x and y coordinates as
rational numbers and you add some
operators to make it a vector space you
can do scalar multiplication and all
that stuff implemented to the point type
of course making sure it's an F fine
space over the vector space so if you
didn't see the top by audition with them
your unfollowers you should really do
that great talk
and with three rational numbers you can
represent any line and you can see lines
purely algebraically you can check are
they like I forget the words okay anyway
yeah yeah like if two lines cross was
the point where they meet you can create
triangles you can check the Pythagorean
theorem and do all this stuff you can
also do I also implemented polynomials
just a state vector of numbers
it actually works on any ring but if you
plug in an integral domain like int the
whole polynomial type becomes an
integral domain which means you could
well and rational numbers are integral
domains so you could make polynomials of
the rational numbers but you can also
make rational numbers out to polynomials
if you want so that's called rational
function and it's like very the type
starts to produce
self and this is very nice this is very
nice right so you can do all storage
sorts of stuff but what if you don't
even have the integers right what if you
don't have natural numbers well you can
also implement the integers much like
you do rational numbers it's an ordered
pair of natural numbers M&M rift and ass
this backslash you read is less so it's
M less M it's kind of like subtraction
so you can think of geometrically you
can think of M is going in the positive
direction on the number line and n is
going in a negative direction so you
have minus 2 there and like rational
numbers you could have M and M could be
different lengths so you can have many
implementations of the same number yeah
so we could implement the integers and
it doesn't need to be a built-in natural
number type like unsigned it could be
any kind of semi ring that is similar so
we only need we're only going to need
addition and multiplication which is
really interesting so total ordering
those are the formulas it's like for
rational numbers but with plus instead
of multiplication
so there's implementation and the other
four operators just call these two
they're arithmetic to add to add two
integers you do this it's it looks like
multiplication does for rational numbers
would be plus instead multiplication is
more complicated but yeah and negating
you cannot negate and natural number but
you just need to swap them and then
think about it on a number line
it's makes sense and then we could use
our template - just using the plus in
line and negation so implement those
three so now everything in this math C++
file still works just fine just
using natural numbers so we could plug
in unsign but let's have more fun okay
first of all of course the interior also
have identity elements so they serve
yeah
natural numbers your own one okay so
let's go back to this could we could all
this math work with Stone Age math yeah
it actually could so I just extended it
a little bit include zero which yeah
maybe they didn't know about zero but we
like mono it's so we have zero so a
default constructor we have the old
constructor for Stone Age people and we
have a new constructor for us modern
Renaissance people so we've passing them
we can pass an unsigned so all this nice
feature yeah exactly so it's like C++
minus 20000 standard yeah so hopefully
if Stone Age people could understand
this code okay how do we do the total
ordering how do you check if they are
equal well strings are equal lengths
then they're equal same number of dots
so that works less than the same thing
yes count the dots addition how do you
add well that's actually string
concatenation now right oh three plus
five is eight yeah good so we implement
that but remember string concatenation
is not commutative we want plus to be
commutative oh actually this because
we're not dealing with the general case
of any possible string we are stealing
the strings with the same character
repeated and then it is commutative so
that's nice it works then we come to the
problem multiplication so multiplication
for natural numbers that's repeated
addition right that's a lot of work if
you have a lot of dots so to multiply 12
times three it's like 11 string
concatenation sometimes
you need a computer to help you write so
yeah of course we could just do it
simple naive loop computers are fast so
that's good
so we have our multiplication works and
we just need the type function so empty
string is zero string with one dot this
one so at this point it's I mean it's
this is how the numbers types are built
up logically so it should be obvious but
it still kind of boggles me when I think
about okay so I take like derivatives of
a fifth degree polynomial or like
checking Pythagorean theorem and it's
all done with some complex combination
of string concatenation and checking the
lengths of strings it's all it tough of
course really inefficient slow but it
works just try it out it's in the code
and yeah that's kind of marvelous ok but
is it good enough ok obviously it's
super slow inefficient thanks a lot of
memory but yeah and where is the slow
part well is this right there's a loop
here it has to be there that we should
optimize ok so this is quite stupid to
do it like this can we do it better so
remember what what's the important
property of string concatenation it's
associative right so if you want to
multiply 12 times 3 we could do this
linear same silly way or we could use
threads right we split it in two perhaps
and we get down and half the time but
that would be kind of stupid as well
right because we're not dealing with the
general case of different strings where
do we know that both of these will be
equal so why don't we throw away the
threading and just do it just take the
first one
and we double it ok so but we're trying
to implement multiplication we cannot
multiply it that's a problem but how do
you double a number if you don't have
multiplication just add it to itself ok
so we saved 1 2 3 4 5 string
concatenation that's good
okay so this works on even numbers
because you could split in exactly in
half but maybe we want the x 13 so
that's the problem right so we have this
extra one at the bottom but we can still
fix this we could put that aside and
round it down so we have still 12 times
3 or 6 times 3 twice and then with just
an extra one to add the end probe
numbers and since every natural number
is either even or odd we can do any
multiplication and the next logical step
what is that
recursion yes use the search tippity and
we are down to 1 2 3 4 5 instead of 12
concatenation so number scroll large
this becomes better and better okay so
how old is that idea you think it's very
very old so this is a piece of papyrus
called the Rhind papyrus I think it's
about 5 meters long it's over three and
a half thousand years old and it's it's
full of examples of how ancient
Egyptians did arithmetic and geometry
and so on and it has this algorithm in
it okay so that looks very very ancient
to us but actually the idea must be much
much older because well this is the
first written evidence but ancient Egypt
lasted for a crazy long time so to go
back to these famous buildings it's a
millennium before that and I don't know
we don't have any actual proof but I
don't think it's a far-fetched to think
that Egyptian engineers knew something
about multiplying large numbers
efficiently even that's my theory anyway
so whoever invented this it was very
long time ago so here is that algorithm
in sort of modernized to C++ still using
that old type but it's just five lines
of code and it'll include zero as well
which the options didn't have in that
way but let's just look at them lines
quickly so first of all if you're
multiplying by zero we're done this
returns zero second line if you
multiplied by F first numbers one we're
also done we return the other one
otherwise we call ourselves recursively
passing in half of the first number
round it down and twice of the other
number where we double yes by adding to
itself and then we're done if we have an
even number but we might have an odd
numbers we need to check that in that
case we have to add one extra and then
we're finally done and it's easy to see
like how fast this is what's the
complexity of this algorithm log n yeah
we divide by half so we quickly get down
to the base cases so this is this makes
this you could use some Roman numerals
for example it makes multiplication so
feasible to do by hand even in such a
primitive system that's really nice but
it's also using two functions that I
didn't implement right half and it's odd
so we need to do those so how do you
check how do you divide in half what do
you do a bit shift over the length right
that's rounding down oh it's perfectly
okay so if you if you think about the
binary representation of unsigned well
you're like if if it's an even number
the least significant bit is a 0 so with
that sort of gets thrown out but we
don't lose any information but if it's
not number we lose a 1 so you think of
that one it's representing that extra X
that you have to add back in for odd
numbers and of course to check your
phone numbers odd let's check the
leasing FN bit now I take I create a new
number how to have two lengths so I'm
not bit shifting that I'm a bit shifting
the
but notice that these two functions are
using bits operations that are machine
instructions really fast so this
actually is very simple those are simple
to implement in binary hardware so I'm
not a hardware guy really but as far as
I understand this AI algorithm
it's used by hardware people to
implement multiplication in binary
computers it's a good way to do it so
but it's good for software people to
know as well because we can do more with
it
so but I'm gonna leave that as a
challenge so if you have not if you
don't know the answer to this I really
recommend don't look it up the result
try it yourself and see what you can
discover because it's really great
exercise try to optimize this algorithm
so the first thing you don't want
recursion right so that cost memory and
function calls whatever so try to
convert this into a loop version that is
not too reveals it so that itself is a
good exercise in turning recursion loops
it's good to know if you manage to do
that you will see that maybe see it
already there's a lot of unnecessary
work here a lot of shifts and if you
have the loop version you can sort of
unroll the loop knowing what you know
about natural numbers and you can
optimize quite a lot actually there's an
answer to this in Knuth in the art of
programming the second book and Knuth
solution is not optimal you can beat him
if you try it it's it's doable I don't
think it's yeah so work on it a bit and
see if you can beat it well should make
you feel good then also think about how
you can generalize this what are those
what are the semantic requirements of X
0 and X 1 are they even same so what's
most abstract way you can represent this
algorithm that's also leads to a lot of
interesting stuff so
have must be pretty hard to generalize
yeah it's it depends very much on the
type you have to think about yeah it's
so it's such a deep thing this it's
looks this five lines of code but it's
it even leads to some like unsolved
problems in mathematics yeah it's worth
looking to and yeah if you yep yeah well
that's an extra exercise for you to
implement so take my code yep write more
in spirit is inspiration for this talk
and I really recommend if you think this
is fascinating stuff to check into this
to youtube series first guy I learned
about from Harold actually in this
meetup group long time ago I know who
this guy is
is a mathematician in University of New
South Wales I think very active in
YouTube has great courses on math from
like even kindergarten level up so with
this series he has has been going on for
like 10 years and it has an agenda he's
he has very interesting opinions about
modern mathematics and that many things
are wrong with it it doesn't believe the
real numbers even exist or there's no
working definition of real numbers
actually it's just something
mathematicians sort of yeah not treated
in the good way so you need to go back
actually to all their ideas and to
rational numbers particularly so it's
very interesting and it's like a
minority view in mathematics but to
programmer I think it's seems very
sensible like we never we're never used
to real numbers it's always something
were discrete and of course Alexander
Stepanov also this series of talks which
was basis for this book later really
good he also
goes into this abstract algebra
fascinating history about all the people
who developed it very fun to watch
useful stuff for every programmer and
it's it's a big investment in time to
watch this probably take you a year to
watch it so but I think it's well invest
invested time I have not finished first
years okay more inspiration for this
talk of course this meetup group so I
think big thanks to everyone who has
been filming this talks for three years
now like Harold and Paul and Sheila
yharnam yeah I forget a lot of people
but and we have this high quality videos
there have been many previous talks that
have some kind of relation this is not
all of them s what I could fit in a
slide so you can go into this these
talks as well again re-watch them and
dive into other areas of math I think
this is really cool that we have all
these videos you're certainly build up
this treasure trove of great information
that you can build on make new talks
like I did here some final takeaways I
think it's good to know about total
ordering I think it's good to know about
the soceity
especially I think when you're overload
operators don't be to create it it's the
rules should be defined as they are
defined in math and to some degree C++
otherwise you're gonna have a lot of bad
surprises
I think C++ is provides a good framework
for exploring this abstract algebra and
it's like I think it's much more fun
than doing problems in a math textbook
to actually implement this math types
and learn how they work in practice and
I hope I convinced you that ancient
elementary math is good to know about
and study
so there's the links to a talk into the
source code and that's another joke
thank you yes question I've seen the
pros of linear but no not yet
I that's interesting to look into and
see I see what they what choice is
saying yeah yeah so I've seen a talk by
what's-his-name
hi Dave exactly he talked about it but I
have not looked at proposal itself yeah
it looks like more mathematical types
more mathematical algorithms are coming
in C++ probably yeah yes now it's the
time to find the big bugs yeah
definitely
Thanks yeah yeah that's the the name
Sarah one could be a little bit
suggesting a little bit too concrete the
thing but maybe maybe yeah save space on
slides but it also maybe make McKnight
look too abstract also to people so I
don't know but yeah I think it's words
do really matter that's a that's another
example of that yes
yeah yeah okay someone needs to do a
talk about category theory at some point
here I'm not I don't understand it it's
yeah monads and yeah whatever but yeah
yeah there might be good name sir to
look into there's a lot of this yeah
category theory and a lot of modern
mathematics is based on set theory and
that has been it's a dogma and there's
many strange and bad things about sets
so there's a lot of mathematicians are
trying to use category or type theory or
yeah
all this it's a difficult thing to
change all the mathematical communities
view but yeah it we might have been led
astray a bit with sets
it doesn't infinite set even exists it's
like ya can do an infinite amount of
work very deep questions yeah still a
lot of new things to discover yes
question former person no I have not
I'm it's yeah yeah it is and it's
definitely interesting to look into her
no no and it's yeah this is like yeah
exactly say pleased to inform proof C++
is not a good language I think but yeah
and this is like he had talked about
Dijkstra he was very much about formal
proofs and thanks but it's yeah I don't
know enough about that subject either so
but I think just the fact that it works
like it does with this kind of crazy
tile it's some kind of sign that things
are correctly defined I think yeah
yep thank you
[Applause]